To begin with it's useful to understand what object orientated concepts are for your journey
inside of Unreal Engine.
So we're talking about this in terms of a parent child class relationship.
So any class can be derived from making it a parent and a class in inside of Unreal
Engine is just a type of UObject.
So we see here at the bottom, all classes are the child of another class up until UObject.
So we keep almost going down another layer deeper inside of Unreal Engine before we get
to this UObject.
So the parent is found here, so the parent is this large blue block which in our instance
let's refer to this as the UObject which is the most foundational class inside of
Unreal Engine and then maybe we'll build more classes based upon this and the reason
why we do this is because it saves a lot of having to rewrite existing functionality inside
of Unreal Engine that's already there.
If this base class here, this big blue block, houses a lot of foundational code,
we can utilize that in child classes based upon that and just inherit the functionality
and it just makes creating these projects much more streamlined, it builds a more robust
code base as well and it just helps prototyping develop in a faster manner as well.
So to cover what a parent and child class is, a parent sets up inherited defaults, again
referring to this as the foundational code base and it predefines child class default
data and functions and then the child takes on this functionality and it derives it from
an existing class and can override functionality and default properties.
So even if we set some defaults in the parent we can then override those defaults in the
child class and they always extend from a parent class there.
When we're talking about inheritance inside of Unreal Engine we're talking about variables,
so variables could be a boolean or an integer or a float, it's just some variable that
holds some form of data.
We have functions and macros which are really great for housing some kind of code slash blueprint
scripting into almost a modular way which can be reused in other areas of the engine.
We have components which when we're talking about working with blueprints, a component
could be a light, it could be a static mesh, it can be some form of actor inside
of Unreal Engine that we add as almost additive functionality inside one of these classes
that we're creating.
And then we also have these default settings which we refer to between the parent and
child classes in that, say you did have this light component in your blueprint so
we created a component and now we have this light component.
Well the default setting could be the brightness of the light or the radius of the light
and it will come with some default settings which were inherited from the parent
class, however we can override these per actor as well.
So any changes to the parent will affect the child unless the child overrides them.
So that's what's the really powerful functionality, you may have this big parent class, create
a bunch of child classes from this parent class and then you realise you want to actually
change maybe an overall variable, again coming back to this concept variable, in the parent
class which might be the light colour and unless the child has overridden that light
colour, if you change that light colour from blue to yellow for example, all those
child classes will inherit the new yellow colour unless they've decided they want
to be a different colour.